peu connais bien
dans les bras une personne du sexe
opposé connais bien dans ses bras on est
bien dans les bras d'une personne du
genre qu'on appela qu'on est vivant dans
ses bras c'est la vraie prière la
prochaine m.le prochain c'est la vraie g
où le masculin s'accordent avec le fait
mine qu'on est bien dans les bras d'une
personne du sexe en français qu'on est
bien dans ses bras là les creux pour les
boss tout finit par se marier les bons
pour les races et même les colombes avec
les hypers avis
qu'on est bien dans les bras une
personne du sexe opposé qu'on est bien
dans ses bras on est bien dans les bras
une personne du genre qu'on apprend
qu'on est bien dans ses bras là
[Musique]